In 1937,
Amelia earhart was one of the most famous women on the planet for the last
decade.
She had been up ending stereotypes,
smashing records,
and establishing herself as an international role model as she settled for her
greatest adventure around the world,
excursion the whole world was watching.
Then suddenly she was gone,
just disappeared.
And this week's biographics,
we delve into the marvelous and the mysterious life and the death of Amelia
earhart.
Amelia earhart was born on July the 24th,
18,
97 in Atchison,
Kansas.
She was the older of two daughters.
Do you?
Edwin and amy with system Muriel being two years younger.
Edward stands on.
It was a talented lawyer who worked for the railways.
Is Korea,
was blighted by an addiction to alcohol.
Emilia was named after her maternal grandmother,
Millie Otis,
Millie,
and Emilia.
His grandfather,
Alfred,
actually took the girl in and she lived with them during the school year in
Atchison from the ages of three to 11.
During the holidays,
she went to live with our parents in Kansas City.
I mean,
they were attended a private college preparatory school until she was ready for
high school.
Becoming an avid reader.
Young Emilia spent many long hours devouring books of every source,
even though she spent most of the year away from him.
Emilia adored how witty and well educated Father Edwin Woods entertained the
girls and their friends with western thrillers complete with bandits,
Indians,
cowboys,
and other made up characters.
Emilia marveled over his command of the English language and one letter he
addressed her as dear parallel pepitone,
and she rushed to find a dictionary to discover the words,
meaning,
despite his brilliance as a wordsmith,
Edwin was not so lucky when it came to financial matters as a railroad liar.
He never really applied himself,
preferring rather to spend his time coming up with inventions that would make
his fortune.
In 1993,
he designed the device,
do hold signal flags on the ends of trains full of enthusiasm.
He traveled to Washington DC to fill his plans with the patterns office.
After too frustrating days,
he read back to Amelia's mother verse.
A man from Colorado had filed patents on an identical hold a two years ago.
This news is a terrible blow because I had been counseling on receiving several
hundred dollars from the railroad for my flag holder.
We're still the money that Edwin had been counting on was earmarked to pay the
family's property taxes in order to pay the tax bill,
and he had to sell a collection of valuable law books that had been given to him
by his father in law judge.
The judge was furious that his son in law had done these things and a year later
when Edwin took his wife and two girls for a week long trip to the world's fair
in San Louis,
the judge considered the trip and extravagant waste of money and further proof
of headwinds,
spendthrift habits.
Despite our grandfathers reservations,
Emilia loved the trip.
Has she enthusiastically rushed with sister around the 1500 buildings and 12
palaces old lit by these still relatively new phenomenon of electricity.
Her autobiography,
the fun of it's published in 1932,
I mean pinpointed three important threads that attracted her to aviation and
interested in mechanics.
The many railroad trip street took with her father and her love of
experimentation with sports and Games as a railroad claims agents,
Edwin was able to take his family on trips all over the country that travels,
developed and Emilia a deep seated desire to see more and more of the world at
large.
When Emilia wasn't traveling,
she spent hours sitting with our cousins,
knew c and Catherine Shalles looking over maps of faraway places and dreaming of
overseas excursions from the beginning.
The future Aviatrix was a daredevil who acted as if she was immune to danger.
She was attracted to every type of sport,
but she chafed under the societal stereotypes of the day,
which limited gals to reading,
sewing,
and cooking.
She was lucky that she had parents who encouraged her tastes for boys pursuits
and allowed her and her sister to dress in dark blue flannel bloomers gathered
up at the knees for play rather than the customer addresses and Pinafores at
school.
Emilia was known as Millie.
She earns good grades but seem to be rather impatient and she didn't worry about
the details of academic work.
She would quite easily solve math problems in our head,
but couldn't be bothered writing out her working.
This lack of attention to detail was a trait that stayed with the media into
adulthood.
It was at the Iowa state fair in 19.
Oh,
seven.
The two media saw her first aeroplane.
She recalled it as a thing of rust and why that didn't interest her soul and she
wasn't alone at the time.
Neither automobiles nor planes were predicted to become a functional means of
transportation.
In Nineteen Oh,
eight,
Emilia stops living with our grandparents,
Naprosyn and moved with our parents do des Moines,
Iowa,
that she entered public school.
She did well academically.
Despite our problems at home.
Our parents argued constantly,
mainly over money and the constant and drove her beloved father to the bottle.
This was at a time when states across America were increasingly becoming dry.
Public displays of drunkenness were a source of great humiliation as a result of
the public inebriation of Edwin stands in heart.
Soon became the talk of the town,
the heavy drinking eventually led to Edwin losing his job at the railway for
over a year.
He remains out of work.
Finally securing a menial clacking job.
It required that the family moved to simple Minnesota.
The departure from Iowa was a depressing one for the girls,
but especially for that long suffering mother,
as they boarded the railroad car doesn't pull.
She shed tears of frustration.
Life was tough.
Instant poll where the family barely making ends meet.
Edwin's drinking was also still not under control.
On one occasion,
the media found a bottle of whiskey and her father's suitcase and proceeded to
empty it into the kitchen sink and infuriated Edwin and tried to slap the Gal,
but any stops him.
The constant moves that have family undertook during her teen years.
Left Emilia feeling rootless and insecure,
but rather than discussing her problems,
she instead focused on her ambitions.
The family only stayed in support for year with the job awaiting Edwin and the
claims office of the Burlington railway,
they relocated to Springfield,
Missouri.
The move though,
it was a disaster.
After a seven hour train journey,
the family discovered that the job had already been taken for amy.
This was the final Straw.
She demanded a trial separation and took the two girls to Chicago to stay with
old family friends in Chicago.
Emilia shouldered responsibility for her mother and sister as head of the
household.
Her behavior and terror appearance changed dramatically,
although usually attended Hyde Park,
the best public high school in Chicago.
She did not participate in any of the numerous clubs that the school offered,
nor did she play any of the sports that she so loved.
She now referred to herself as a.
He was isolated herself from her fellow students.
She refused to attend the senior banquet,
some graduation ceremony,
a senior yearbook photo caption,
read the girl in Brown who walks alone by the fall of 1915.
Though things have improved in their heart marriage,
Edwin had stopped drinking and the family had reunited in Kansas City for the
next year.
Emilia did not attend school,
but spends her time acting as a buffer between her parents and hoping to
preserve the marriage.
The family fortunes took an immediate turn when any received an inheritance.
She used some of the funds to send Emilia to the Oregon is finishing school on
the outskirts of Philadelphia.
It was there that Emilia polished her social graces which would allow her to
move with ease and poise among all segments of society after she became famous
at the age of 19.
She was the oldest of the students at the finishing school when she entered in
the fall of 1916.
While she was there,
Amelia's feminist proclivities came to the fore.
She gets a newspaper clipping file,
have accomplished women,
many of them firsts in their fields,
but she was no suffragettes.
Next one clipping.
She wrote,
women will gain economic justice by proving themselves in all lines of endeavor,
not by having laws passed for them.
Over the first semester,
Christmas break,
Emilia returned home.
While that she witnessed the ravages of the first world war returned soldiers on
the street with missing limbs or had been blinders or had been otherwise names.
She returned to the finishing school,
but she felt conflicted.
She wrote to her mother,
I can't bear the thought of going back to school and being so useless.
Emilia decided to quit the school and enrolled in a course to join a voluntary
aid detachments,
a group of civilians who served as assistant nurses,
ambulance drivers,
and regular nurses.
After several months of training,
sister Amelia,
as she was known,
was posted to Spadina military hospital on the campus of the University of
Toronto,
working there until just before the armistice in 1918.
She cared for soldiers who had been poisoned by gas and otherwise injured in the
trenches of the western front.
She also looks after pilots from the Royal Flying Corps,
Canada,
who had crashed in Europe.
It was while tending to these injured pilots that Emilia became fascinated with
the idea of flying.
The men would trade stories about their exploits high above the ground nearby.
It was the Royal Flying Corps base and the skies were filled with hundreds of
planes.
Buzzing rounds.
Civilians were not allowed to fly in the planes,
but on their days off,
Emilia spent time with the pilots and attended area exhibitions.
Now the hospital job,
it was intensely demanding with Emilia,
often working 12 hour shifts.
She became so worn down this in the summer of 1918.
She came down with influenza and pneumonia and developed painful scientists,
scientists.
As a result of this,
she suffered from chronic sinus infections for the rest of her life.
After a period of convalescence with our mother,
immediately enrolled at Columbia University studying zoology,
biology,
and chemistry.
She rented a modest apartment in New York City at the end of the spring term,
though she quit her studies,
she would like to claim that she had simply decided against a medical career.
The reality was that she lacks the temperament to wade through years of tertiary
study spending the next year with our parents in Los Angeles.
Amenia put her focus on helping them keep their marriage and tax over the course
of that year,
but now 22 year old Emilia,
we'll take our first paying job,
drive a fast car,
and fly a first plane.
Los Angeles in 1920 was a haven for pilots.
It was full of barnstormers pilots who stunted in asset classes and gave rides.
Do often terrified passengers.
In December of Nineteen Twenty Emilia ends,
her father went to an Air Rodeo in long beach where pilots performed,
spins and dives amid a crowd of spectators the next day and wouldn't pay $10 to
give his daughter our first passenger flights,
a 10 minute ride over the Hollywood hills the moment the plane left the grounds
she knew that she herself has to fly.
It was at that moment,
but she knew she had found her calling without telling her parents,
Emilia signed up for flying lessons with the expectation that Edwin would cover
the $500 feet,
but my father had no interest in his daughter's newfound obsession and she was
forced to find a job as a telephone clock in order to fund the lessons.
She chose to be instructed by a female pilots and Nita Nita Snook.
After 10 hours of lessons,
the media went solo in 1921.
The exhilarating experience encouraged to onto achieving a full pilot's license
over the next few months.
As she progressed in her lessons,
Emilia became an airfield junkie.
She cropped her long hair and to began wearing breeches boots and an oil stains
that the jacket,
the spline complaining about the high cost of lessons she managed to scrape
together the money to buy a fast plane.
This was thanks largely to her mother's inheritance.
This plane was an Esta with a 28 foot wingspan.
Indeed it was the second Esta ever built,
renamed this plane canary.
During these early years,
Amelia didn't consider herself a good enough flyer to appear in public events.
However,
her humility didn't preclude a few appearances to shows and two attempts at
record setting in the La area.
The press was also beginning to mention her as one of the few women pilots in
the area.
By 1923,
she had turned into a confident pilots that she was not a natural flower and
struggled throughout our instruction.
Many men and even some women were pilots than Emilia,
but that persistence and so bravery cetera pass.
In 19,
24,
Amelia's parents,
marriage finally ended in divorce,
a devastated Emilia saw no reason to stay in California and she relocated to
Boston along with her mother and her sister.
The following year,
she re enrolled at Columbia,
switching to majoring in engineering.
That's when she scored a c minus in Algebra.
She wants again,
quit her studies.
She then applied for admittance to mit,
but was turned down
over the next few years.
I mean he works as a number of menial jobs.
Eventually she ended up as a social worker at a settlement house in Boston in
1928.
Her three year hiatus from flying ended when she agreed to take a seat as a
passenger in log keeper on a flight from New York to London.
The plane was a Fokker f seven,
the three meter float plane piloted by Miss Stoltz.
The flight plane took off on the morning of June the 17th,
then arrived,
did Barry Points in south Wales nearly at 21 hours later,
despite her role being a minimal one,
Emilia was now in the books as the first woman to fly.
The North Atlantic,
resounding to the USA.
Emilia developed a close relationship with George Putnam and New York
businessmen and form a publisher.
They had mess when she had interviewed for a place on the APP.
Putnam helped to improve our flying skills and to embark on a series of lecture
tours intended to promote the aircraft industry and to encourage women to become
pilots.
Over the next few months.
She wrote her first autobiography,
20 hours,
40 minutes about a flight across the North Atlantic.
On November the 22nd 19,
29 Emilia Saturday women's speed record for a single engine monoplane.
The following year,
she purchased a Lockheed Vega executive and in it she broke the speed record for
a course of 100 kilometers.
Emilia and George Putnam were married on the seventh of February,
1931.
Over that next year.
She sat and spoke at several altitude records on the 20th of May,
1932.
She took off from newfoundlands in her vega,
touching down in a field of cows in Londonderry,
Ireland.
Fifteen hours and 30 minutes later she had just become the first woman to fly
solo across the North Atlantic
with her husband's flair for publicity.
She quickly became the most famous woman flyer on the planet's Portland build
his wife as lady Lindy,
capitalizing on the massive popularity of Charles Lindbergh.
Immediate was now a fully fledged celebrity when she made public appearances.
She needed police protection.
She bronch downs by designing a range of clothing.
There's coffee table look in January of 1935,
I mean the.
I became the first woman to fly from Hawaii to California in that he or she also
wrote our second biography,
the front of this while continuing a hectic schedule of lecture tours and public
appearances.
On July the 20th,
1935,
Emilia celebrated her 38th birthday.
She knew that she couldn't go on breaking records forever.
Yes,
she still had one more big ones and knockoff.
In fact,
it was the biggest of them all and that's of course a flight around the world.
To achieve a round the world flight.
Amelia would need a bigger plane.
In early 1936,
she purchased a twin engine,
lucky 10 e electric airplane.
That was the product of the finest technology available at the time.
It was a low wing monoplane of metal construction with constant speed propellers
powered by to Pratt Whitney,
wast [inaudible] 14,
550 horsepower engines.
The interior of the plane was modified to take extra petrol tanks giving a
theoretical range of 4,000 miles as announced to use of 4,000 feet.
The plane was also fitted with one of the very first sperry automatic pilots in
order to relieve the physical strain of flying on Emilia.
Despite this innovation,
it became apparent that Emilia words need navigational assistance to fly across
the Pacific Ocean or navigational knowledge was rudimentary and so Irish bond
navigator Fred Noonan,
was recruited for the world record attempts.
Noonan was keen to be involved,
but that was one aspect of the navigational set that he wasn't happy with.
The only way the navigator could reach the pilot was by crawling along a catwalk
over the intervening fuel tanks.
All system was devised.
Web I resend messages,
could be clipped to the line of a bamboo fishing pole and passed between them,
but this inadequate method in pad,
the crucial element of teamwork,
the plan's route for the round the world flies began in Oakland,
California with the first landing place in Honolulu,
Hawaii from them.
It continues in a westerly direction,
taking advantage of prevailing winds in order to maximize publicity.
Partner required his wife to keep a detailed diary and post entry stem from each
stop.
He would edit them so he could rush out the book as soon as she achieved the
record.
Now the first leg of the round,
the world flight took off from Oakland's at 1630 on march the 17th,
1937.
The flight to Honolulu,
it was smooth and uneventful,
taking 15 hours and 47 minutes.
The next stop was to be the tiny American territory of Holland island,
1,800 miles away.
Immediately things went wrong.
The plane swung to the rice just after to take off.
Then grounds looping.
As the undercarriage collapsed.
Fortunately,
Emilia managed to land without any injury or fire,
but the world record attempt had to be put on hold as the plane was created and
sent back to Lockheed for rebuilding.
The rebuilding was completed on May.
The 17th efforts were made to reduce the weight of the plane,
one of which undoubtedly contributed to the tragedy that was to come,
the trailing area,
which allowed them to request a bearings on 500 kilohertz from ground stations
was removed three days after the rebuilds electra was delivered to them,
Emilia Ans Noonan took off from Oakland's for the second time because of
seasonal changes.
It was decided that this new attempt would be done in the reverse direction.
The first link was to Miami and then onto Puerto Rico,
Venezuela,
Dodge Guinea,
and in early June if you ones in Brazil,
the following days,
we spent servicing the engines and checking the instruments.
The 1,900 mile flight across the South Atlantic was made on the seventh of June,
landing the car,
Senegal Virginie across Africa and it for days it was followed by the longest
leg of 1,950 kilometers,
do karate and India.
There the plane was serviced by Imperial Airways along with members of the
British Raf on June the 17th.
If you want to dumb dumb near cal Calacatta landing in the middle of a
torrential rainstorm after refueling of Bangkok,
if you want to Singapore,
from there as onto bang done in Java here,
the electric develop some kinds of instrument false on the flight to Sarah buyer
in East Java.
The problem reoccurred forcing them back to Bandung,
whether where repair facilities on June the 29th they flew to lie in New Guinea,
the 1,200 mile flight was completed in seven hours and 43 minutes so far the
paranoid traveled 22,000 miles.
The Pam must have been extremely tired by this point,
but the greatest challenge,
it's still lay ahead of them and that was of course crossing the Pacific.
The next objective was howland island,
some 2,566 miles away.
The two spans June the 30th in preparation for the mammoth flight,
several witnesses,
so they should reported that a noonan was drinking heavily on this day and we're
still doing so in the evening.
As Emilia attended a dinner party,
they took off at 10:00 AM on July.
The second eye witnesses reported that the Electra lifted off sluggishly,
sang downwards towards the sea,
and then began a very slow claim to the east and no one ever saw them again.
The last known position of the electro was near the Nigga manny violence.
The last radio message from Amelia was,
we must be on you,
but gas is running low.
Have been unable to reach you by radio.
We are flying at 1000 feet.
The official search efforts to find the missing plane and it's famous occupants
lasted until July the 19th,
1937.
The RNC search by the US Navy and Coast Guard was the most expensive in u.
s history,
still no physical evidence of the plane or the remains of Emilia in Newnan
wherever found over the decades the speculation over what happened to Amelia
earhart has intensified in 2017.
A photo emerged that purported to show we're back view of Emilia and sitting on
a pier in the Marshall Islands.
However,
this photo was debunked when it was proven that it was actually taken in 1935 to
years before Amelia disappeared.
Then in March of 2018 and anthropology,
professor at the University of Tennessee named Richard Jensen argue to the
bones,
found on the islands of Nikki,
my in 1940,
where 99 percent likely to be those of Amelia earhart.
The bones were analyzed in 1941 and determined to be those via mail,
but John's believes that that analysis was deeply flawed.
Yes,
other scientists uphold the original findings.
While we may never know what really happened to you immediately,
it depends quite certain that's the tantalizing mystery of her disappearance.
Well,
keep her name in the headlines for many years to come,
so I really hope you enjoyed that episode of biographics.
If you did this,
a couple of things you could do right now.
One is hit that like button below.
Also,
if you want more stuff like this,
we put out brand new videos every Monday and every Thursday,
so hit that subscribe button below and subscribe button doesn't do what it used
to on Youtube.
If you actually want to get a notification about these videos,
please do hit that bell button next to the subscribe button and that'll send you
a notification every time,
every Monday and Thursday won't put out a new video.
Also,
if you want to watch something else right now,
suffering the archive over there on the race,
and as always,
thank you for watching.